um drew locke the guy that as of a
couple of years ago we thought may be
the answer he hasn't been able to stay
healthy he hasn't been consistent here
he is
addressing the rumors that still
continue to hover about the possibility
of oh aaron rodgers becoming a member of
the broncos
how are you able to
block out the rumors of the broncos
activity this offseason with stafford
maybe watson maybe rogers maybe fields
was that difficult
uh no
believe it or not no
it was not
um
because
i decided that
i was going to develop a plan in this
offseason
it would be really long days but it was
going to be worth every single second of
it
because regardless of what happened if i
stayed here if i left
they brought someone in
um
my mindset was not going to change
wherever i went if i went somewhere if i
stayed here i was going to be the guy
and i put every single ounce i had into
that this offseason
and
being able to do that
gave me zero time to be able to listen
all this stuff that
you know maybe one day i'll go back and
read and laugh about all the things that
were being said from these people
that end up being completely wrong so
boy mike
yeah drew just uh it's still kind of
going on with aaron rodgers right so
are you not even paying attention to
that and then i
have to
follow up on that you know that the
aaron rodgers trade rumors
it's all out there
um
no we had a great practice today
um
dove into
the
script that we had for the last couple
days getting ready for this and you know
i was happy with the way we played out
there and that was
you know my number one concern was how i
was gonna go out and play
and the seven on seven stuff we had
today i know that was it we didn't have
any full team but we did seven on seven
and that was my biggest thing and that
was my focus these last couple weeks
and i kept my
thing the same over these last couple
weeks even when that stuff kind of
started popping up
yeah uh he ain't real thrilled with this
at one point i did notice i did i did
notice i did notice the scratching in
the corner of the mouth with a middle
finger i don't know if that was
oh there was a few yeah i mean there was
a few body language things they were
like
you know i mean you always have to watch
you always have to watch
any scratching adjustment of the glasses
there's all sorts of things you can do
when you got four fingers to choose from
with the one
that uh happens oh there it is there it
is i think that was to you sometimes
sometimes you're on a conference call
and you know you're fixing your hair
when somebody says something you don't
like i mean we've seen all sorts of
examples of that
in recent years he says all the right
things he said all the right things
there i mean of course hey yeah he's
bothered by it i mean he can't you can't
you can't live in denver and be an
athlete those fans are psycho out there
the sports media psycho out there you
know the nuggets and the rockies could
be in the world series in the nba finals
and it'll be the third story on the
local sports radio they'll talk about
the broncos otas first that's just what
it's going to be so he's not avoiding
that he's hearing it out there i've
lived there i've been there you can't
avoid it out there they love their
broncos so it's tough yeah but he's just
kind of kind of got to focus on what
he's got he's got talent he could be a
star he has star type talent and last
year it wasn't great but there was a lot
of good i do think people are
overblowing a little bit like like oh
man they gotta find somebody new i i
don't know i don't see it that way i
think he showed enough good to where i
would give him another crack if he can
beat out teddy bridgewater here and see
where it goes because i think there's
there is a reward there's a big reward
to maybe be had with this guy at
quarterback
he's only entering year three right and
i think part of it is
even though he fell to pick 42 overall
second rounder
because he was regarded as a first-round
pick yeah
the expectations were almost as high as
they would have been if he had been
right a first round pick and it didn't
help that guys like us were like oh here
they go they got their guy they got the
guy john elway is finally drafting his
guy here we go watch out he had that big
game against the texans in december of
2019 yeah but again it's injuries it's
an effectiveness and i think that's
what's conspired to create this
narrative that he's not good enough i
agree so hey i i admire the guy
for strengthening his resolve busting
his butt he's been working with peyton
manning he's been putting in the effort
he's trying to become the best version
of himself that he can be that's all
anyone can try to do whatever your
ceiling is
put in the work every single day to get
there in any line of work whether you're
in school whether you got a job whatever
it is always put in the best to be the
best version yourself you can be i
admire him for that but it's not an easy
situation teddy bridgewater was asked
same question yesterday and he you know
same idea i try to ignore it i ignore it
i don't pay attention to it how how can
you not how can you knock chris yeah how
can you no you you can't i mean you know
i i was in tampa
after i lost my spleen i was still on
the roster and you'll remember this
there was all that talk about brett
favre coming to tampa bay now like i
wasn't going to be able to compete with
them or beat them out so i i was a
little bit just like oh whatever because
i was still
recovering and all that but
even as you try to block it out like
you're saying you can't there's no
possible way you you every show you turn
on it's on there you hear it in the
locker room
whether it's players talking or now the
media is asking other players about it
so it's it's it's there's no way you can
avoid those type of situations as a
quarterback you know you do what they
kind of just said you block you block it
out as best you can
and just focus on you that's what the
nfl is about you said it right it's
about being the best version of you you
see where you go from there and can you
make it happen and you can't worry about
all the other stuff or you'll you'll
drown in all the noise in this league